white nationalists self-described alt
writers and some militia movement groups
are planning to come out in full force
on election day tuesday november eighth
with the goal of scaring off black
voters typically democratic voters as
you know in an effort to help their guy
Donald Trump defeat Hillary Clinton we
have heard from neo Nazi leader Andrew
Anglin we've talked about him before he
plans to put together thousands of poll
Watchers across all 50 states the alt
right website the right stuff is touting
plans to set up hidden cameras at
polling places in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania they plan to be handing out
liquor and marijuana in the city's quote
ghetto on Election Day to try to induce
residents to stay home how offensive is
it to think that if you just show up at
a predominantly black polling place with
alcohol and weed black people will just
forget that they were on their way to
vote and they'll take the weed and the
alcohol and just go home did this is
just it's the lowest of the low in terms
of what we have come to see from these
right-wing white nationalists all right
type movements a representative of the
alt right website the right stuff
actually wrote an email about this which
I will show you saying we are organizing
poll Watchers in urban areas to cut down
on the most traditional type of voter
fraud of course the kind that barely
exists we also will have stationary
cameras hidden at polling locations in
Philadelphia illegal to monitor anyone
that comes in to vote and make sure that
the same people are not voting at
multiple locations a Pennsylvania is not
even going to be closed so I don't know
why they're worried about that and let's
let's put the the graphic back up if we
see people voting in multiple locations
the footage will be submitted to the
Federal Election Commission as well as
put out on social media to undermine the
legitimacy of Hillary Clinton should she
steal the election the National
Socialist Movement and various factions
of the Ku Klux Klan have actually uh
also been involved in deploying people
to watch the polls either informally or
as they say through the
Trump campaign which is also informal
unless you're actually registered as an
election monitor and then you have our
buddies over at the oath keepers that's
the former law enforcement and military
members who have coalesced around
walking around with guns in a group
called the oath keepers they are
planning to show up very heavily armed
and they're advising their members to go
undercover and gather intelligence that
sounds like something the oath keepers
would do now Donald Trump has been
telling supporters for weeks and even
months the entire thing is just rigged
it's gonna be stolen we need to activate
people well that's what we're seeing
here Pat the repercussions of that are
potential real-world violence and these
people say that they're out there to try
to stop boater fraud but really it's
just giving them an excuse to go around
and bully and intimidate minority groups
really they're rigging the election by
causing some boaters to be suppressed
and stay home and the Trump campaign did
not comment on this of course as we know
Donald Trump not racist but popular
enough to get an endorsement from a KKK
newspaper to activate multiple factions
of white nationalists to go stand at the
polls and intimidate black voters I will
say it again if you see voter
intimidation reported do not be
intimidated do not engage with them but
most importantly do not let them cost
you your vote check out our segment from
Tuesday November first about what to do
call the police there are numerous other
places to report it and I want to put up
the information one more time who can
you report intimidation to number one
the election protection hotline 1866 our
votes number two the US Department of
Justice voting rights hotline at 800 253
3931 and you can also report this to
local and state officials this includes
poll workers your County Clerk the
elections commissioner the election
supervisor or your state board of
elections and please if on Election Day
you might remember in 2012 uh there was
a video that went viral of someone
pressing a Barack Obama and it selecting
Mitt Romney and we published that video
that same day Election Day
millions of views national media
coverage if you see anything on election
day that we should be aware of and that
should be made public get it to us right
away and we will get it we we will be
publishing YouTube clips throughout the
day we will put together a story and get
it out on youtube and start sending it
out through a platform so that if there
is something that needs to be seen
before the end of the election day we
will get it out there and this is so
important that people should not just
sit back and say I'm sure it's fine I'm
sure no one else is being intimidated or
impacted by this voting machine or that
voting machine or whatever let anybody
who will listen no and we're certainly
on that list yeah and it's looking more
and more like this election is going to
be decided by a razor-thin margin we
don't want to see what happened in two
thousand without voting purge lists in
Florida that we don't want that to
happen again yeah and we don't want this
to come down to forty thousand votes in
Ohio the way we saw in 2004 either be it
get out and vote report intimidation and
please just be aware that these these
lunatics are going to be out there but
do everything you can not to allow them
to affect your vote it's just a few more
days until the 2016 presidential
election and if you're confident about
what the results will be on november
eighth you can actually put your money
where your mouth is if you go to bed d
si.com and use promo code pakman 25 this
will give you a free $25 to back your
favorite candidate you can bet on this
election in a number of different ways
on Betty si.com you can look at Clinton
versus trump you can look at state by
state races the electoral college
etcetera and of course there's a whole
bunch of other stuff you can bet on if
that's your thing I am mostly interested
especially now just what hours mere
hours before the results of the 2016
election start coming out in what does
our audience think how confident is our
audience in the election predictions
that they've been sending me both on the
left and the right for months now you
can actually make some cash if you're
that confident that you will ultimately
be right and vindicated if you go to bed
d si.com which has been around for over
20 years and my viewers and listeners
can use promo code
would pakman 25 to get a free $25 credit
for your election bet